good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy monday hope
everyone had an amazing and fulfilling
weekend i hope you had such a fulfilling
weekend that you're so fulfilled that
your cup fulfilleth oh you're oozing out
with fulfillment that's all i hope for
you
my wish for you my wish
for you
is that this life would be all that's
fulfilling for you all that you wanted
all that you wanted how was your weekend
it was great i spent so much time with
my gorgeous stunning nephew harold two
days in a row back to back it was
extremely fulfilling
your cup fulfilleth over my cup
fulfilleth over 100 and i went out on
friday night i've been reading a lot it
was a great weekend i'm so happy for you
you're so refreshed rejuvenated right
i'm literally ramona singer season four
renewed you are renewed we love to see
that here at the toast
an equally fulfilling weekend i got to
spend a lot of time with my dear sister
who i love so dearly margot
i actually did see her which was quite a
treat to be counseled by the fulfilling
the whole weekend was fulfilling it was
very family i saw some friends we just
had a really nice time that's all you
can hope for a gorgeous june weekend
let's stop bragging let's stop bragging
about our great weekend a gorgeous
fulfilling june weekend that is leading
us into a gorgeous june week full of
five episodes of the morning toast we're
gonna be here recapping tv pop culture
talking about ourselves today we've got
a great day it's monday so we've got a
full weekend of stories and we have just
like a full slate we've got them burning
yourselves yes which is our new monday
segment for those who are new here you
can write in on burden yourselves
gmail.com tell us something embarrassing
you did over the weekend and we'll help
you unburden that burden yes
you what we'll have you on that burden
and we watched the platinum jubilee this
weekend which was so exciting and
incredible i'm so excited to recap it
i'm sure it was really
fulfilling
dare i say the world yeah because i'm
not even british no nor are we part of
the commonwealth and i was deeply
fulfilled and moved
by what i saw 100 we obviously have
stories about it um i was here and then
i was there because i was so moved you
know i was initially like right here
and then i was right there
because the queen moved me yeah i love
that even though she wasn't there no
even though she wasn't at the jubilee
also i watched the first episode of real
housewives of dubai so i will recap that
lots of thoughts i like can't i can't
find i'm searching literally high and
low for the energy to turn it on and
there's something inside me like i'm so
unmotivated tldr
dw too long did not watch let me break
it down for you which is that you don't
need to watch just yet right my
thinking like the episode was enjoyable
it was giving like such season one of a
new franchise where everyone's trying so
hard and they're like i'm the baddest
[ __ ] in this town i can say that in
four languages and it's like they're
trying so hard and
it's
try hard i think i'll do what i did with
the real housewives of miami and watch
it like in the middle of the season
that's what i'm gonna do too because i
couldn't care enough to watch this every
single week and i think also they're
coming into their dynamic you know some
people don't know each other but every
time it takes time so i will
get a lot of episodes together and then
watch when i have time i can't care
enough to watch every single week but it
has promise okay good i mean it has
money which is really like all they need
yeah but it's like there's so much money
that it's like not even a factor so it's
like everybody has to bring something
else something more that's interesting
and everybody is really interesting so
you have to bring even more than that
yeah and it was just giving a little try
hard and like cringy season one vibes
yeah no but that's expected with the
season one of a housewife i did like
what they did on real housewives of salt
lake city where i believe they were
filming for like months before they
actually started quote-unquote airing
like there was so much footage before
season one episode one of the real
housewives of salt lake city so it was
nice we like caught them in the middle
you know
yeah
so they have to get into a groove and i
will catch up with them when they do but
i can't like have the bandwidth
especially because it's like the same
night as beverly hills and the same
knight as kardashians it's true i can't
be watching each week so that's my those
are my thoughts but i'm i'm glad that
it's here me too okay i'm totally on the
same page cool um other than that i've
read a couple of erotic novels this
weekend that were extremely good would
you like to recommend any to our deer
toasters yeah not deer toasters let me
you know all these erotic novels like
start to look the same you know because
it's literally the same no it's like one
night on the beach yeah she and him went
there okay so right now i'm reading
chasing love by cat t mason which was a
tick tock recommendation it's like it's
actually really good so much so that i
had a dream about it i haven't read this
one yet but it came from rach parcell
uh crossing the line with lucy score by
lucy's score and i made it into a movie
um i also read not erotic at all start
without me gary jannetty's second book
not erotic really good i love short
books like gary is the king of that and
for that i have the utmost respect and
then i read another wow i read a lot of
lucy score pretend you're mine
you can skip it like it was fine but the
one that i initially read from lucy's
square that started me on this journey
was the one snatcher recommended that's
pretty much like you know
pronoun pronoun now now you know things
we never got over that you can't start a
title with things no it's so big such a
blah word yeah and i really feel like
the percentage of like the chance that
i'll remember what a book is about like
a couple months from now is i know
you're not supposed to judge a book by
its cover but it's really based on its
title you can judge it by its title yeah
like so many of the books i've read are
very similar because i have like two
three genres celebrity memoirs which is
easy to differentiate like whose book is
whose erotic novels
and like thrillers and a lot of the
thrillers and erotic novels like months
later become the same book like i don't
know also the book it happened one
summer which is everyone's favorite
erotic novel the title was this over the
summer no
great question and that book really
stood out
despite its cringey title the title
makes no sense it should have been it
should have been what the book was her
dad like sent her away for the summer
okay but it should have been what the
next book was called which nobody read
because nobody cared about the sister
yeah which was called hook line and
sinker because they were like fishermen
yeah that's a good call and that was
really good if you haven't read that
book like what are you doing it happened
one summer so if i can get tested late
um how many books have you read this
year so far not a lot how many check
your goodreads like 11 and i read four
of them this week but that's pretty good
i guess i just really haven't been on
vacation lives
eliza but that's where i like do most of
my reading and i just get into like a a
thing it's so me like i will read a
thousand books in a day and then not
read for six months that's you yeah i'm
all or nothing girl something cute about
you just a little fun fact about me yeah
my reading my goal for this year was 30
books because i figured i'd be busy this
year with the new bebe and all and i'm
on track i've read 14 so far i just
checked and i'm in the middle of one but
i just i can't muster up the [ __ ] to
give so yeah i need to start something
else but then all that time i spent
reading that book i've got to finish it
yeah you have to finish it just to get
the one yeah exactly um so yeah we're
also bookworms
and we've got a great chat i think we
should just dive in i think we should
because there's so much to discuss so
without further ado
do bryce and stress we miss you here are
the fast five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast
oh my god
are you okay no oh my god it's my rdh
flaring up oh i would be remiss i would
be devastated oh i might even be
heartbroken if i didn't tell you that
today's episode is brought to you by
starbucks bia energy drinks that feels
good to let out
the relief with caffeine naturally found
in coffee fruit it's energy that's good
it's a beverage that is crafted from
caffeine naturally found in coffee fruit
as well as antioxidant vitamin c they
come in three delicious fruity flavors
like mango guava raspberry lime and
pineapple passion fruit it is a
refreshing fruit flavored boost of
feel-good energy in a way that only
starbucks can deliver so personally i
like the mango guava best and i'm not
really like a big coffee drinker so i
don't like wake up and drink coffee so
it's nice if i need a little boost to
have something that's not obviously
coffee to drink and we have them in the
studio i really like them it's a perfect
drink when you're being active outside
it's fruity and refreshing starbucks buy
energy drink is available online at
grocery stores convenience stores and
gas stations nationwide again that's
starbucks bia energy drink today's
episode is also brought to you by
manscaped who doesn't love a man who can
appreciate the finer things in life a
gold medal here a gold watch there but
we love a man who goes the extra mile
walks with a little bit of spunk and
confidence
manscaped would like to introduce you to
their best and biggest ultimate hygiene
bundle yet the platinum package 4.0
manscaped is the leader in shaving your
man's precious jewels now trust them
with the whole shebang join the 4
million individuals worldwide who trust
manscaped by going to manscaped.com for
20 off with and free shipping with the
code toast so their new platinum package
4.0 is the biggest bundle they've ever
offered giving you a bulk discount on
manscaped top products without
sacrificing top quality for your quality
man the 4.0 package is the one one-stop
shop for the man who deserves it all
they designed this package to give your
man all the best products for his
hygiene routine so you'll find their
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer the weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer ultra premium
body wash ultra premium two in one
shampoo and conditioner ultra premium
deodorant crop preserver anti-chafing
ball deodorant crop reviver spray toner
anti-chafing boxers the shed travel bags
all of their fabulous products are
packed into this platinum package 4.0
both of our husbands use manscaped um
ben loves the trimmer obviously he uses
the ear and knows one he uses a lot of
their skin products it's really a
fabulous brand and a great gift also for
father's day coming up get 20 off and
free shipping with code toast at
manscaped.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscaped.com
and use the code toast it's time for
your man to enjoy the finer things in
life with the platinum package for his
platinum package manscaped.com code
toast thank you claudia it's a pleasure
our first story is all things platinum
jubilee the queen's 70th platinum
jubilee extravaganza concluded this
weekend with a party at the palace
concert which we talked about before it
was supposed to happen we said who was
going to be performing that it was going
to be projected onto buckingham palace
and i was like i was underwhelmed i
couldn't imagine it
it was incredible it's sensational
actually we watched the whole live
stream i do have some thoughts negative
thoughts but let's start with the
positive thoughts first i just want to
say the whole weekend was really a joy
to watch the family was out and about
obviously the queen skipped some things
that were rather torturous and she's 96
because she's 96 and she wasn't present
for quincella because it's like an
all-day concert and i'm sorry she
doesn't know who some of these people
are but she was probably in her bedroom
listening clapping along saying jolly
good show jolly good show and it was
definitely queen chella it was queen
jello that's an amazing call okay so
let's start from the top i think the
sketch that like took everyone by storm
was the queen and paddington oh my god
that's how it kicked off they're having
tea and paddington offers hair a
marmalade sandwich from his hat and then
she shows that she has a marmalade
sandwich in her bag because like that's
what she's always carrying around and
her acting chops were excellent what can
she do that's a really i agree i was
like very shook by her
um professionalism yeah she was so she
was also in that bond sketch for the
olympics a few years ago yes so this
isn't her first rodeo no not at all and
then it kicked off with queen performing
we will rock you and just the cutest
moment
was when they were with their spoons and
their teacups the paddington queen
moment was so
sweet i couldn't think of like a better
you know like iconic british thing
than paddington it never would have
crossed my mind for that to be the
opener i would have thought like adele
like something it was so sweet it was so
precious and when he was like thank you
ma'am and she was like that's that was
very sweet when he said thank you and
we're like oh and then he goes for
everything oh my god it's too much you
have a tear in your eye
are you alive it was too much and you
know the whole vibe of the
the jubilee was
obviously like thank the queen for all
of her work but it did feel like this
like send-off for her like
kind of this assumption that we wouldn't
have another jubilee obviously because
she's 96. so there was this like
finality to it that made the whole thing
kind of like sad
yeah it was bittersweet and it felt like
the end of an era but i
the party that they put on there was
nothing sad about it like no everything
was done to the nines i don't know who
was the director of this party at the
palace but they should be doing the
olympia the super bowl the oscars they
should be given like every job it was
phenomenal the production value was
insane like there were so many moments
when i had such chills besides for the
insane graphics being projected onto
buckingham palace which was just
gorgeous and so well done they had these
drones in the air with different symbols
they were making teacups and her dogs
and her initials her purse her purse it
was so iconic and so professional like
it was honestly unlike anything i'd ever
seen no totally and just to take in the
magnitude of like a lot of these
performance edit performers and i love
that they had smaller artists all the
way up to bigger artists and they were
missing some big artists which we'll
talk about yeah but to see them
performing like in front of the palace
with all these like union jack flags
around them like i'm not even british
and i was feeling british pride yeah no
it was giving patriotism like it was so
it was so it was really beautiful and to
perform for the queen even though she's
in her bed behind you
must be the honor of a lifetime we watch
me we watched the whole thing but maybe
when his performance was so good and
then she posted on instagram like this
was the best day of her life to perform
for the queen and i imagine like like as
a british as a young british artist does
it get any bigger than that i really
don't think so no it doesn't and i agree
i like that it was like really quincella
in the sense that they were smaller
artists and bigger artists smaller
artists during the day during the day
and then the bigger artist at night and
i want to go through all the performers
but i will say there was like
kind of like a
like a glaring um absence absence from a
lot of you like for me the fact that i
think the most famous perfect person who
performed was elton john and he was
literally not even on stage he was like
inside buckingham palace and they
projected it for this on the screens
like that was odd to me and i really
felt like there was star quality missing
like and the more i thought about it i'm
like where is adele where is harry
styles where's little mix
where's little where's the spice girls
reunion yeah like i felt like there was
star power missing and that's not to
discredit the people
i think for harry styles you could maybe
say he's on tour it didn't work out or
like
or like he's kind of like young and edgy
like i don't know i could have
i could see a world in which harry
styles was not asked but i do not see a
situation in which adele was not asked
and i guess little mix wasn't asked and
i know they would get back together for
this a hundred percent and like where
was the spice girls reading and they did
a uh one of the artists diversity did a
act yeah they're like this like um
spoken word dance they were amazing they
were amazing the act was 70 years of
british music and basically highlighted
everyone who either didn't show up or
has already passed away so it was like
the beatles it was one direction bg's
one direction spice girls and it just
was like where are these people niall
horan should have been should have been
there yeah doing a solo act one
direction should have gotten back
together for it like it's the queen i i
completely respect i completely agree
but it also gave us a chance to
highlight some smaller british artists
who you might not have known or you knew
and you're like oh my god it's so good
to see this box 100 and i have to say
like i was most impressed with adam
lambert first of all queen opened the
show which is like it went from
paddington to queen
to queen
and obviously freddie mercury is not
alive and adam lambert has become like
the official sub in for freddie mercury
and he was
incredible like first of all this is
probably the biggest thing that's ever
happened to him in his career like he's
had such a unique career like didn't
even win american idol had a part on
glee release amazing bangers that nobody
cared about and that was like like the
unofficial official lead singer of queen
he was
amazing like his vocals are so supreme
he was having so much fun his outfit his
makeup it was amazing like i think he
was incredible and i think he deserves a
lot of credit yeah no and it was a great
way to open the show and
i loved
loved that and it got the crowd going
yeah then there were a bunch of other
artists i don't know the exact order but
there was jax jones who's a producer who
sang with mabel there was mimi webb who
we love she sang house on fire
there was sam ryder sam ryder who i
follow on tick tock and to have watched
his journey is incredible like went from
singing on tik tok releasing his own
music has become the official uh uk
submission for eurovision and now was
performing for the queen in the cutest
union jack jumpsuit love i ever did see
i love watching people on tick tock
thrive george ezra who was one of
synagogues so handsome uh duran duran
rod stewart saying sweet caroline prince
george stole the show that's like the
moment that's going viral like him
singing along and when we were watching
it we're like oh that's a song that just
everybody can get behind
and when you saw george and william
singing it together it was so cute so so
cute it was really like an amazing night
a really like honor and a tribute to the
queen and i enjoyed it immensely yeah
diana ross was also there iconic yeah
alicia keys was there she sang empire
state of mind which confused people but
i'm just never going to be confused by
people who want to perform their best
songs for the queen their best songs
even though she should have sang um
girl on fire
by the way i was thinking she was going
to sing girl on fire some people live
for
like that's her like most popular song
yeah i thought that was weird yeah
empire state of mind the more i think
about it like this in front of
buckingham palace yeah it's like a song
about literally like new york and
america like right right it's weird it
might still sting first i thought for
sure she was gonna sing girl on fire
because the queen is literally and she
should have changed it to queen on
fire's queen is on fire
they should have really consulted us for
this musically yeah i had ideas like up
the wazoo but honestly they did a great
job they really didn't need our help
yeah my only like negative thought or
feedback was like the lineup
no it's just what i love that people did
i loved the lineup
but where was the rest of it where was
the start where was the second half
where was evening headlinings harry
styles at coachella he can do coachella
but he can't do queen chella i know and
adele like for real adele it's like she
actually like needs to put out a
statement that's how obvious yeah like
her absence was so glaring yeah i think
i imagine the british people feel the
same it was weird i googled it and there
was obviously like this whole uh our
article in the telegraph like where was
it oh yeah
those brits nothing gets past those
brits no but it was really great and you
should watch highlights on youtube if
you haven't oh also the andrew lloyd
webber uh lion king mashup yeah so good
lin-manuel miranda like had to show up
and ruin it but it was really good
yeah he did have to do that oh surprise
james corden wasn't there honestly
shocking also did you see the videos of
um george and charlotte they were with
the uh
orchestra who was playing we don't talk
about bruno and they were doing fake
conducting they were having the best
time so cute well you know i feel like
this entire week and i really got to
know the kids a little bit better yes um
and here's what i've gleaned
the oldest one like he's ready like he's
george george he is so well behaved he
looks just like his dad did when he was
that age he knows the the burden the
chip on his shoulder and he is fully
embrace it he was so well behaved i feel
like the monarchy is in great hands with
him honestly he's four years old she
ready the middle girl charlotte is so
unbelievably stunning so also extremely
well behaved gorgeous hair she's gonna
be like you know
like i think like what diana was like
how people are just gonna like fall in
love with her yeah like an icon fashion
girly here there for sure that little
one is a little troublemaker he's a
little uh he's a little
a little rascal yeah and he's going to
be uh he's going to be a troublemaker
he's going to be the harry the harry the
party boy
now again he is still a child like he
could grow up to be like george but
we'll see no he likes
to get into trouble and i think i said
this last week and i know that this is
like exactly how genetics work but both
all the kids look just like their
parents like exactly half and half yeah
they do charlotte looks so much like and
they also look like happy kids you know
because they're well behaved but they
they are they're enjoying themselves
right and they're not self-aware enough
to like put on a face like if they're
miserable and start their kids their
time is you'll know they're layman's
right right and you're right they seem
like really happy and it was a nice
affair yeah it was really a great moment
and then at the end of the weekend the
queen emerged once again on the balcony
in her green
iconic and it was a great weekend for
the royal family also we need to talk
about whoever is doing the royal
family's tic-tac-toe
because the tick tock and reels videos
were so premium so informative like not
stuffy they were also but like not like
try hard queen doing the renegade so you
have to toe a line when you're like a
brand on social media especially a brand
representing kensington palace right you
have to be on trend you have to be like
in the know but you can't be cringy and
you can't be try hard so there's a real
like you have to walk a line and i agree
i was really impressed with the content
coming out of kensington palace i
learned so much that chariot the gold
cherry she was rolling down and also
they projected her
carnations everything was just tops
technologically advanced
really um tugged at the heartstrings and
all in all it was a really gorgeous
affair and a gorgeous tribute to a woman
who was given the country that i don't
even live in so much so much like she is
a history book oh and another thing they
did great was like gathering videos from
celebrities around the world obviously
they had paul mccartney they had
michelle obama they had all these big
names judy judy dench just wishing her
well and it was really sweet to know how
many people she's touched still no adele
still know what it's not even a video
right if she couldn't make it she could
at least put a video in well i think
maybe her line of thinking was like if i
make a video it'll be so much more
obvious that i'm not here no it just
feels like she's boycotting the platinum
jubilee like she doesn't want the queen
to have served 70 years that's what it
feels like you know what it's giving
it's giving disrespect honestly like
anarchist i don't know what's going on
but like i need a full reasoning as to
why adele didn't play like i will not
rest until i get down to the to the wire
on this yeah
maybe she's like not a royalist maybe
she's an anarchist that's what i'm
saying oh my god
that's true i guess we just assumed she
supported the crown like maybe she
doesn't maybe she doesn't but i feel
like british people like love the like i
don't think is that like a thing that is
it is a thing
but
i'm not caught up on my british politics
but maybe maybe she does whatever the
political part maybe she's like with the
protesters yeah it was an active war
that would be wild that would be wild
i don't think so though because
regardless like she's the queen yeah
she's given her whole life yeah to the
country
no and i imagine like when you
grow up in the uk like the queen is so
much a part of like your
like the zeitgeist they're like you
can't forget about the queen you know no
and it will never not be an honor to be
asked hundred
of course oh somebody performed comedy
i'd love to throw a stand-up comedian in
there
yeah
it was really really great you guys i
mean
i was surprised i haven't been so
everything is always less than what you
expect it to be and this is so much more
agreed and they undersold it in the
marketing oh big time
big time huge i've been listening to so
many songs like from
the lineup like queen chella that like i
totally forgot about or didn't know
queen shell is she's an influencer they
need to make a queen cello playlist on
spotify yeah from kensington that's what
i'm saying like there was nothing
like
there was no ancillary marketing or
anything sponsored they just like got
together and put on this sickening
concert and like no one else is
promoting it and it was beautiful like
right outside the palace those trees
that long street i don't know what it's
called that like brings you yeah into
kensington palace it was buckingham
palace it was beautiful it was beautiful
andre buchelli performed breathtaking
and then the uh the girl who performed
what a wonderful world with like the
greenery yeah
the royal ballet there were some campers
up there dressed as bees stunning it was
gorgeous it was gorgeous okay so check
it out if you haven't because
chef's kiss yeah and queen thank you
ma'am
thank you ma'am
are you ready for our next story
what goes up must come down i have some
bad news oh no michael b jordan and lori
hardy have broken up after one year
together they are both completely
heartbroken and if that's the case why
not get back get back together this was
shocking unbreak your heart say you love
me again
like it's so simple if you're both
heartbroken get back together no no
so simple this is so upsetting and i saw
a statement
i don't know if it was legit like from a
source basically saying like he was
ready for like full settle down and
she's not yeah the source says one
michael and laurie are both completely
heartbroken they still love each other
couldn't be true if they're breaking up
yeah get back together it's a simple
solution
are you a solution-oriented person
because if you are get back together the
source also said michael matured a lot
over the course of their relationship
and was ready to commit for the long
term he let down his guard with her
opening up emotionally in a romantic
relationship for the first time they had
great times together and brought out the
best in each other this can't be true
otherwise they would still be together
right
no but then that makes sense as to what
i'm saying like she's not ready for like
full you want to know like i think this
relationship like really skyrocketed her
to like a crazy level of fame and she
wants to like enjoy it before she's like
settling down uh yes but like really it
doesn't get better than michael b jordan
i know yeah there's nothing else out
there trust me like it's just michael
it's just him yeah i'm really upset
about this because they were like truly
a power couple who gave us a lot like
great paparazzi photos they weren't shy
about their relationship yeah like they
weren't like please respect our privacy
no no privacy they were like supporting
each other on social media giving us a
lot giving us everything this is very
upsetting even though like the small
glimmer of hope is like now we have two
extremely eligible like good-looking
young people in hollywood like it'll be
fun to watch who they date next even
though i don't think it's really ever
gonna get better matched than the two of
them yeah also he is 35 and she is 25 so
that would
oh you know he might be at that place
where he's ready for more and she might
be like just coming into her own oh you
know what that's actually i didn't think
about that i didn't realize there was an
age difference that's a really good call
but they should have thought about that
before they took our hearts cried
totally but that does make sense you
know she's like now extremely famous she
was like well known and really rich
before because of her dad but now she's
like fully her own celebrity she's a
skincare line have you been hearing
about the drama yes she has a skin care
line called skin skn by h
and a lot of people are
comparing it obviously to skin by kim
which is really similar yeah but she
hasn't said anything she hasn't said
anything and i is is she skn by lh like
always or just skn
skn by lh like that's what she
trademarked oh i don't know the legality
of it i just know a lot of people are
comparing the two got it well if they
both got trademarks which they did if
they're both selling products then
yeah i think kim's trademark issue is
with a different company a facialist in
brooklyn like a skincare like a store
that's a different issue yeah yeah yeah
so i don't but
kim has a trademark but that other girl
did the trademark office said there's
room for all of you no the trademark
office will rule in favor of whoever was
using it in the market first not who got
the trademark no but they're also
registered under different services so
the trademark office already said this
is fine you think kim went to went to
market with something that wasn't
trademarked no yeah no i don't think
she'll have a legal problem i think
she's just getting like you know online
backlash right but if the trademark
office said it was not a trademark
infringement then
uspto reigns supreme yeah they need to
they need to issue a statement totally
them and adele and michael and laurie
for everything they're putting us
through yeah it's it's really disgusting
but the way that i'm coping with it is
with a bit of denial like i think
they'll get back together and then by
the time that they don't like she will
be with someone who i already am
shipping heart yeah just like kim kanye
pete you know you need to
you know what really needs to happen
like steve needs to sit them both down
he's extremely appreciative yes he's
very wise he's lived a long life he has
a really he's been married for like a
hundred years he can offer them both the
wisdom and guidance that they so
desperately need he will be the one to
fix this
steve will
guide them home
100
and ignite
their bones
steve will try
to fix them
that's beautiful jackie thank you that
song's in my head from snatcher stories
the spatula the snapchat
i heard that the queen listens to the
snatcher oh i didn't hear that i heard
she listens to the morning toes and
that's why she wouldn't go to the
concert because they didn't ask her to
perform that's what i heard no i started
on two more i heard that the queen
listens to the morning toast and she was
boycotting the jubilee because they
didn't have me perform my iconic hit
song toast yeah and that she was upset
with paddington for not taking a piece
of toast out of her bag because she was
like i have my morning toast what's
marmalade jelly jam
yeah
okay
marmalade lady marmalade of course the
queen is lady marmalade uh by the way
like we needed pink
we needed pink at that jubilee needed
needed there was kelly clarkson
throw her in there oh we need to talk i
know we don't ever like to say anything
negative about queen of the universe
miss kelly clarkson but last week we
were raving about how but in order for
you guys to know that all of our
enthusiasm is authentic it's also
important to talk about when we're not
enthused so last week we were so
overwhelmed excited talking about kelly
clarkson's new album kalioke which as we
discussed last week is an ep of six
cover songs she records um covers on her
talk show the kelly clarkson show and a
lot of them get really popular like her
billy eilish cover so she's decided to
release like six or seven songs on an ep
all covers of old songs and we were so
excited until
until the set list dropped yeah we got
the track list and it's not it's not
giving good there's only six songs on it
which already is disappointing
considering she's done over 500 covers
wow we text so much because the first is
happier than ever which obviously we
were thrilled about here's the track
list one blue bayou two call out my name
three happier than ever four queen of
the night
five trampoline
six fake plastic trees like dead ass
i've never heard of any of these songs
no literally i was disappointed like
queen of the night sounds familiar let
me just figure out it does sound
familiar
queen of the night
arya by mozart oh whitney houston oh i
don't know it because i know a lot of it
i'm sure if i played it we would know it
but i don't want so we have been
listening to the happier than ever cover
and it's really good i just wish we were
going to get some more contemporary
music yeah and more period yeah you did
500 yeah maybe like i've heard of two
and if this flops she probably won't do
it again and it might flop because of
this these song choices
yeah so then we're not gonna get other
covers yeah i guess i'll just have to
start tuning in to the kelly clarkson
show every day oh no oh no premium
content every single day what is this
the morning toast
are you ready for our next story if it's
the next story that's brought to you by
ivory ella
it is ivory ella is a lifestyle of power
brand that donates 10 of profits to
saving the elephants and other
charitable causes launched by college
students ivory ella grew organically
into one of the largest and most
passionate communities of supporters
wanting to make a difference in the
world they've donated over two million
dollars to date and they continue to
deliver good clothes for a good cause
so they have over half a million donated
in their first year to save the
elephants and over two million donated
to charitable causes a minimum of 10 is
donated to on all of their products
every time you buy from ivory ella you
are making a donation to a cause that is
important to you like save the elephants
autistic
self-advocacy network cyber smile
foundation reef restoration foundation
the american heart association hearts
and bones and more everything you buy
you are helping save the world little by
little and they make really comfortable
cute and trendy clothes you can be a
part of the herd get go get yours with
15 off using code toast at
ivoryella.com
collections slash new dash arrivals
that's code toast for 15 off and the
website is ivoryella.com
collections slash new dash arrivals
great thank you our next story we're
going to continue on this low and then
we'll pick back up because rascal flatts
guitarist joe dunn rooney has pleaded
guilty to a dui
if life is a highway joe dun rooney
attempted and failed to ride it all
night long after crashing into a tree at
4 a.m last september that's a good
little uh opening line they got there
yeah page six always with the zingers
the rascal flats lead guitarist pled
guilty to the dui charge that resulted
from his inebriated joyride which
culminated in the collision just outside
of nashville the court sentenced him to
two days of jail time for which he must
report to begin serving on june 8th
two what what two days of jail for this
two days he pled guilty
okay um
disappointing beyond i
like there i have a lot of like hate in
my heart for people who drive drunk like
it's for me it's like an unforgivable
sin like i never got back on sam hunt
train like i can't even look at him not
that he's anywhere for me to look um so
this is really hard because this is
hitting deep it wasn't hard for me to
give up sam hunt like i wasn't really
crazy about him before but rascal flats
is obviously a band that's extremely
near and dear to my heart and i'm really
upset i'm not even hurt i'm disappointed
yeah there are so many celebrities who
have dui i'm sure if i told you i'm like
you have forgiven and loved some of them
still
um do a list of celebrities with duis
it's very like popular for some reason
remember in the real housewives of
beverly hills when bella hadid got one
at like 15. yeah that was crazy that was
crazy okay uh robert downey jr you don't
subscribe doesn't matter paris hilton
nicole richie kevin hart
michael phelps okay but like here's
vaughn before you keep going like not
that i could ever understand drunk
driving but like if you're a person with
a car and you're drunk like you need to
get somewhere like i get it if you no i
don't get it but if you are a person
with unlimited means to drivers
helicopters planes uber
it's just really it's unforgivable
it's
unthinkable yeah who else
justin bieber what amanda bynes tiger
woods nick carter ooh that hurts aaron
carter um shocked
natasha leone
samantha ronson heather locklear
many of like my favorites you know no
but like
and saw their mug shots too it's
extremely common for sure like in
celebrity culture which makes no sense
because nobody has access to more means
of getting around than celebrities yeah
like if you're a celebrity if i was
literally like an actual celebrity i
would literally never drive myself
anywhere i'd have like a full chauffeur
and like a limousine me neither and
which would be hard because i'm always
driving no you don't even have a license
so
yeah you're gonna change for me you're
not you're not gonna get a dwi because
you don't drink and you don't have a
license you're gonna get uh like
arrested you're gonna get pulled over
for driving without a license you're
driving too slow literally you've got a
license yeah exactly so this is
definitely really upsetting i hope he
thinks long and hard while he's in jail
for two whole days um he pled guilty and
he's going to jail and i'm assuming the
person like he didn't hurt him no he
hurt a tree right okay the poor tree but
it's not a human being which is yeah
thank god nobody was hurt yeah but that
i guess always will bring like your
sentence up a lot if there's other
people involved of course it's very
upsetting
please don't drink and drive it's
literally
the dumbest thing you can do yeah when
uber exists and lift
and taxis
and buses and trains and subways
truckers again shrinking and driving
behind yes what is that noise
that's not truckers there's been parades
like all throughout the city i think
it's a parade bagpipes is it st
patrick's no no
it was just st patrick's day and i got
caught in the middle of the parade oh my
god hell on earth was trying to cross
the street during the st patrick's day
parade i don't even want to talk about
it it was the day sophia with an f was
co-hosting with me we were both like two
hours late because literally the parade
yeah it was horrible no disrespect to
the irish just like just parades in
general parades disrespect to parades
yeah for sure on like the busiest street
in new york city yeah no like why don't
you have the parade like um
like
anywhere else like just anywhere else
there are so many things about new york
like that where it's like why would you
parade in central park why would you
come here for that no wait seriously why
don't they have the parade in central
park
central park i mean it's supposed to be
like a beacon of peace in an otherwise
chaotic city that's its intention but
it's really not
it is if you go into the park you kind
of forget that you're in a city okay
they should really have the parades in
in the park
like the bike path or the reservoir you
know that would just like go against the
founders of the parks the principals
yeah the principals of the park and then
things would get out of control people
drop things all the time at the parades
and like yeah it would be disgusting
yeah the park is just like this little
piece of slice of heaven suburbia yeah
yeah
are you ready for our next story it is
it's a lot and i really look forward to
your thoughts because i hadn't heard
this yet there's a new show coming out
called all star shore where reality tv
personalities from across the reality
universe will light it up on paramount
plus
so here's whose cast are ready to go to
the canary islands where they will
battle it out for a cash prize and
global bragging rights we have jersey
shores angelina pavarnik bachelor in
paradise alon blake hortsman
love is blind giannina jabelli rupaul's
drag races vanessa vanjie mateo our
emotions angie
van you know the craziest thing about
vanjie sure she was the first one
eliminated on her season like she should
have been
completely irrelevant like there's so
many queens they call it the pork chop
when you get
uh eliminated on the first week but when
she was exiting she did the weirdest
thing she was like walking backwards and
she was like her name is vanjie she was
like vanjie
then she and she stood there for 10
minutes saying her own name and it was
so iconic she got recast on rupaul's
drag race review she has like a
full-blown career from that one moment
good for her yeah talk about making the
most of every opportunity yeah
yeah so what do you think about this i
mean i feel like mtv does this a lot
where they do like different shows like
x on the beach with people from
different
reality tv franchises and i've never
watched it i've never really heard like
unreal things about it it just kind of
sounds like a gathering of losers you
know that's exactly what it is and these
days there are so many reality tv shows
there are so many seasons there are so
many
former stars looking for things to do
yes and they're looking for shows so it
makes sense but yeah how why not just go
on x on the beach this is for paramount
plus so it's like you know the ultimate
girls trip version right i guess that's
a good thing
even more content yeah um
but yeah it's just giving
wait blake and giannina are dating and
so they're going together yeah i guess
that's interesting
it's just like these are people i
haven't like generally given a [ __ ]
about in years like yeah don't get me
wrong when giannino was on love is blind
season one like i was obsessed followed
her on instagram but i could slowly
unfollowed her and like i'm just not
interested anymore like i really have a
have a short show because there's so
many new reality shows coming in new
reality stars i have to cycle out old
ones and so the people who end up on
these shows are people i haven't even
given a thought about in years
yeah but you know what it's it's pretty
smart it's like all these people like
still have a lot of instagram followers
that are just like sitting dormant the
executives are let's like let's activate
yeah
and then we get things like this i will
say like to my core i find angelina from
jersey shore like for some reason it's
like i never really got over the fact
and i think i i've i've said this before
you said it on clubhouse to vinnie yeah
to vinnie like i feel like i was such a
jersey shore die hard fan i've rewatched
it a thousand times and if you watch the
show like you know that those kids gave
their all they became stars enough for
nothing like they were giving us the
most and angelina was on two seasons and
both times she left like so she really
wasn't a part of making the show the
phenomena the cultural phenomenon that
it was and so for her to be asked back
for their new show and just like get all
the accolades and all the perks that all
the others got without having to like
bleed out for the show like sammy
sweetheart literally like going through
the most manipulative relationship of
her life all on camera like they all
gave so much and i just feel like
whenever i see angelina it kind of
bothers me that like she likes those
opportunities forgave her and let her
back into the fold but one she missed
out on all those years of success and
those were the big years so she didn't
get that
two
you know she they invited her back to
this show now and it's not what the old
show was in terms of
fanfare so it's not like she's getting
everything yeah and i imagine she's
getting paid far less than the other
people yeah i don't know so like just
her yeah no i wouldn't she's in this
person i would still hold a grudge
conceptually she just or like that that
irks me i would still hold a grudge for
sure for sure are you ready for our
fifth and final story
is it
already already it went by so quickly
it's
the fine
why can't i sing too we sing it together
but i always sing the first three words
for sure but we're always improving so
why can't i be a part of it wow wow okay
um no okay just like no how about that
wow the final story you think i'm gonna
back you up now
exactly what i
[Music]
the queen's jubilee may have some
marmalade
well thanks
it's not the same
fifth and final story really crazy
disney apologizes to a couple whose
marriage proposal was thwarted by an
an evil employee
a nuts employee this video went so viral
all over the internet this weekend if
you haven't seen it just go watch it it
is so disturbing i think it's disneyland
paris yes so the viral video was first
posted on reddit last week and it showed
a man getting down on one knee to
propose to his girlfriend on a platform
in front of the sleeping beauty castle
sleeping beauty castle mid proposal an
employee rushes up and snatches the ring
box out of the man's hands and ushers
the couple off the platform so he
interrupted the proposal because he was
a stickler for the [ __ ] rules and
just like couldn't let the magic happen
at the magic kingdom make it make sense
so now disney has apologized saying we
regret how this was handled we have
apologized to the couple involved and
offered to make it right right now now
the this is obviously like a disney
adult couple i'll preserve my judgment
because it's not relevant to the story
line not jermaine not your main so this
is obviously a disney couple and they're
now probably gonna get married at disney
for free like they better yeah just
imagine being that person like when
someone gets engaged in public whether
you're in a restaurant
at a disneyland park like everyone it's
such a magical moment like no matter how
old you are yeah jaded cynical it's just
like everybody stops and is like oh
everybody watches everybody claps you
know at least we have up until this
point in humanity also if i i think it's
nice that there's like a general human
unspoken rule if someone's getting
engaged in public like maybe in a
crowded space like and you see it
happening
i see videos of it all the time people
know to move the [ __ ] out of the way
like they give people space it's like
the one time people like humans act
civilized right it's really nice like
there is like this general unspoken rule
understanding amongst human beings when
other people are getting engaged you
give them the floor right and so this
employee like obviously you're probably
not allowed to be up on the platform and
that's the rule he was told and he's
just trying to do his job but like to be
so joyless and to see that moment and
think like oh gotta be a tattletale
right like gotta be a hall monitor wait
for her to say yes she asked he asked
the question and he literally ran
between them grabbed the ring box which
is hutzpa dick theft and was like come
downstairs so if he really was that big
of a stickler for the rules like be a
human being let her say yes let them hug
and then come up behind them and be like
sorry can you move down the steps of
course no but the whole thing is like
that this person saw a proposal and that
their heart didn't flutter and instead
they were like rules no what has this
person been through
yeah this is giving heartbreak because
like you're obviously like you hate love
obviously why do you work at disneyland
paris yeah if you're so joyless and i
can imagine like obviously i would never
get married at disneyland i'd literally
rather die or engaged but i imagine like
if you're a disney adult like it doesn't
get better than this and disneyland
paris i didn't even know that was a
thing me neither so this much like as
much as we think it's like oh like bad
for them imagine you're a disney adult
and like it happens to you like it's
soul crushing it might like take away
the magic they might stop become disney
haters join my side yeah but i do think
like there is a way for disney to make
it up to them and like this video went
so viral like they they have to do
something big and so i hope that these
people are able to like have the disney
like dream wedding whatever that entails
like mickey and minnie cutting the cake
or whatever um and like really go above
and beyond for them that's the only
thing that can make it right yeah for
sure i'm sure whatever they do will you
know
make it so much better better than they
and now they have this great story
and by the way at the end of the day
like nothing bad happened no everyone's
alive like that's fine it's fine no but
like that video did like hit me i was
like what the [ __ ]
it just like it gave me like a little
pause i'm like
what the
literally what the [ __ ] yeah it was
weird it was very bizarre weird he was
just so excited to be a snitch yeah he
was so excited to like be a dick a
snitch and a snatch
he literally was it was smooth he was a
snatchler he was a smooth criminal
literally
so those are the best five stories you
definitely needed to know them every
last one of them um and we're not done
because we have unburdened yourselves
which is our segment here we do on
mondays where you can write in to
unburden yourselves at gmail.com and
tell us the mortifying things you did
over the weekend and we are going to try
to make you feel better i have read the
three today and they are hysterical i
can't be on believe can't wait and it's
brought to you by zocdoc a free app that
shows you doctors who are patient
reviewed take your insurance and are
available when you need them you can
read up on local doctors get verified
patient reviews and see what other real
humans had to say about their visit so
when you walk into a doctor's office
you're set up to see someone in your
network who gets you go to zocdoc.com
choose a time slot whether you want to
see a doctor in person or do a video
visit and just like that you're booked
find the right doctor that is right for
you and book an appointment that works
for your schedule every month millions
of people use doc doc and we're two of
them it's our go-to whenever we need to
find a book a doctor especially when i'm
on tour and i'm like in random places
that i obviously don't have a doctor
it's nice to get on a video chat with
someone like when i got bit by a bee and
it turned into a rash like it's nice to
get a professional when you're traveling
and away from home
in the chaotic world of healthcare let
zocdoc be your trusted guide to find a
quality doctor in a way that is
surprisingly pain free with zoctalk you
can get your doctors in a row
go to
zocdoc.com toast and download the zocdoc
app for free and then start your search
for a top-rated doctor today many are
available within 24 hours that's
z-o-c-d-o-c
dot com slash toast zoc doc dot com
slash toast okay ready
hey girlies yesterday at work three of
us girlies were talking in a break space
one of the girls marriage is hanging on
by a thread they just started going to
couples counseling beyond just the
marriage this girl's just going through
a lot and i've been helping her out as
much as i can well after reading us one
of the messages he wrote in their group
chat with their therapist i started
ripping the sky to shreds i was over his
[ __ ] and it got everyone in the room
going on just like a bass bashing
session on the guy the wife included
after a few minutes the girl looks at
her phone and the color drains from her
face as the panic sets in somehow our
entire conversation recorded and sent
into the group chat with her husband and
her therapist there's no way to delete
it and she's terrified now of all these
truthful feelings being out there and
that it might be the official end of
things this would be her second divorce
okay i mean it's not your fault that's
literally the worst thing that can
happen in general but you know what
considering they're on the brink and
these are her truthful feelings was she
not sharing the truth before is this
news to him this could be the thing that
saves them i know i think it might be no
it might be the universe's way of like
saving her a lot of time and just like
it's obvious cutting to
the heart of it and it could be the
thing that saves their marriage or saves
her so much time and they might have to
end things but
yes this is so uncomfortable first of
all at least it's not you yeah at least
it's just your friend like i'm sure if
the wife were writing in i would feel
even harder for her but you know what
the truth never hurt anybody honestly
truth will set you free
actually sorry the truth has hurt
anybody that's literally the phrase
truth hurts um what i was looking for is
the truth will set you free and even
though it's painful and it's gonna be
awkward for her like i don't think years
from now she will regret having
accidentally spoken her truth yeah just
the embarrassing thing for her is that
she's like talking crap about her man's
like with the whole office no totally
but that's how bad things have gotten
yeah no it's a reality check for
everyone yeah i don't think it's that
bad honestly i think it'll move the
needle and it's they've got to move i
just hope that you don't know this man
yeah sounds like you don't because you
just keep saying the husband like you've
never met him yeah hopefully but it's
fine you know what i think at the end of
the day this is something you'll
actually be grateful happened
maybe maybe maybe that's a stretch but
you could find the good in it yeah hello
beautiful stunning and smart ladies i
have been deeply mortified for the last
48 hours and truly need to unburden
myself i own a coffee shop next to a
music venue and a famous country artist
visited before his show i gave him some
free merch hoping he would showcase it
around on tour or even wear it to the
show because this has worked in the past
he seemed so thrilled and said he tagged
us on instagram as he shook my hand with
what i perceived to be a flirty grin i
definitely thought there was like a vibe
i happened to be going to see his show
that night when he tagged us on
instagram i was able to dm him back and
see when he was active which was very
exciting anyways i go to the show and i
get rather drunk and sloppily tried to
slide into his dms he doesn't read them
no harm no foul i then proceed to drink
more and these concert cups are huge i
was doubling my seltzer intake by
accident i wake up the next day to my
absolute horror and see a novel of
desperate dm's to him from my business
account this man is getting straight up
hit on by a coffee shop and to make
matters worse he read them all and left
me on scene i'm still shaking from this
mortifying experience and pray my shop's
name is not tarnished from this thirsty
toaster's action love a newly single
country fan i don't think he'll do
anything to your shop
and you know what
if he's like a famous country artist
this happens all the time like not to
diminish you but to make you feel better
like you're just one in a million yeah
and you know what like nobody was hurt
nothing happened he saw it he's not
interested i'm sorry to say
just forget it just forget just on the
burden drop it down over there don't
pick it back up this happened to someone
else not you and try not to do it again
but like even if you did like serious
like in nothing materialized you know
it's just you oh like you just were
embarrassed yourself and the story no
but let's say
like a co-worker saw the messages and
it's going to tell them it's your shop
you're okay you're okay yeah and if you
do run into this guy again like like you
said he's famous he means a million
girls who i'm sure like throw themselves
all over him like he's not gonna
remember so you're the only one
remembering it which is the best thing
let it go even if he remembers big whoop
yeah so what you put yourself out there
like come on don't be so it's really
that's nothing it's okay it's okay just
set it down don't pick it up this one's
not so okay okay
i'm absolutely mortified i was having a
spectacular day driving home from a day
of shopping and i saw my boyfriend's
truck waiting at the light as i turned
down the street passing my boyfriend's
truck i made a really vulgar face at him
this face we all know it
peace sign with your tongue in between
i made a really vulgar face to be fun
and playful i could see he waved but his
windows are super tinted later i found
out it was my boyfriend's father driving
his truck to run an errand i am shook
still embarrassed and ashamed typing
this i texted him to apologize but yikes
this ruined my day
what are the chances that the father
doesn't know understand the gesture
that's what i was thinking yeah but you
texting to apologize i might have
alerted him to like he probably thought
oh my crazy silly you know future
daughter-in-law sticking your tongue out
i don't think
i think maybe by texting him you might
have made it worse because i don't think
he initially i don't think adults know
what that is because they see a peace
sign and they see
tongue out they don't see like vagina
licking you know yeah or do they maybe
they're smarter than maybe they're
raunchy yeah um
[Music]
i would just disassociate from this yeah
someone else some other time you know
maybe the windows were blurry and he can
say that like he can think that's what
he said but that's not what he saw you
know i would just deny till you die i
would deny till i die the apology does
make that difficult yeah and i would
deny that you apologize yeah i would go
into his phone and delete the text
messages and start gaslighting him yeah
and like older people forget stuff all
the time yeah it's not a big deal and
like there's always something seared in
their memory yeah but i don't think so
not celebrities older people really know
this yeah they don't just be like oh
that's a goofy face my daughter-in-law
did right these young kids are crazy
yeah
i think you're fine honestly like
it's fine again you sound funny like
here's the thing we have to remember
zoom out from the from the lens of the
big bang theory right not a big deal not
a big deal think about we talked about
this on patreon episode by the way
patreon has been fire patreon.com
morning toast but we talked about when
you think about like something from the
perspective of like the big bang like
and how time is so long thousands of
years humans have been on earth you went
like that once not a big deal no
literally the world is not even impacted
by it like whatsoever not at all nothing
changed no it's so true like move on
think about it on the burden officially
thank you to everyone for being
vulnerable and writing into us again
this is a safe space and if you ever
want to confess something mortifying you
did unburden yourselves
gmail.com and that's our show that is
our show
thank you so much for listening to the
morning to us the milani morning show
where we deliver the fast five stories
that you need to know every monday
through friday on youtube so if you're
watching this on youtube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up and subscribe
did you hear what she said
subscribe we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcasts can be found
so that's spotify itunes stitcher public
radio i heart radio cast box all the
places so wherever you listen to podcast
find us morning toast leave a five star
view about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are hope you guys have an
incredible and crab monday don't forget
to rise and grind don't forget it love
you guys and we'll see you tomorrow bye
bye
bye